okay I invite you to discuss the topics
of the David Pakman show and other
political topics on our subreddit at
david pakman.com slash our EDD i t
spotted a couple of interesting
discussions this morning that i wanted
to point out to you one of which relates
to health insurance which is a very
interesting comment from a british
viewer who says as a Brit it's mind
boggling that people say but Sir what
about the insurance companies as if it's
more or as important than actual effing
lives yeah this is something you know I
it's perfectly reasonable to say you
know the reality is that right now a lot
of people work for insurance companies
and a lot of people work in medical and
insurance billing so if we drastically
changed our health insurance system to
one that gives everybody coverage and it
kind of disconnects the payment systems
that we have from the ability to receive
care could be Medicare for all it could
be a nationalized system whatever I get
it a lot of people who work in health
insurance health insurance companies
medical billing and all of that
bureaucracy are going to lose their jobs
isn't saving people more important than
propping up an industry that shouldn't
even exist this is sort of like with
coal right yeah coal miners are going to
lose their jobs and they're gonna have
to find other jobs and some of them are
going to have difficulty doing that and
as an economy as a country as a society
we'll have to figure out how to support
them but isn't getting rid of dirty
polluting coil a coal a higher and more
important priority than saving those
jobs and it's stunning to me when people
concern troll around insurance companies
that are making profit off of providing
people health care simply so that they
can live good lives and I get it as an
American you don't have to be a Brit as
an Argentinean American I completely
have the the exact same point of view
also from the david pakman show
subreddit joe biden advisors are mad at
bernie sanders his team over allegations
yes so i have no reason at this point to
believe that this is true but
it's being asserted that the recent
string of women who say joe biden made
them uncomfortable by how he hugged them
for example there have been assertions
made that it's the Bernie Sanders
campaign that has been getting those
women to make these assertions and
putting that together for the time being
Pat I've not seen any actual evidence of
that although it's been asserted
numerous times have you heard anything
about it beyond just the allegation no I
haven't and I'm not entirely sure that
allegations against Joe Biden would help
Bernie Sanders feels like on the one
hand I understand Joe Biden is leading
in most of the polls even though he
hasn't announced yet but on the other
hand I think Bernie Sanders and his
supporters want a bunch of establishment
Democrats to run because then they would
split up the vote amongst one another
and allow Bernie a path to the
nomination so I'm interested in looking
and learning more about this for sure
yeah that's interesting yeah I agree
it's not totally clear that just
attacking Biden is the best thing for
Bernie anyway not to mention that unless
we have evidence that he did it we
really shouldn't be saying it those
discussions and many more on the David
Pakman show subreddit david pakman.com
slash re d di t